bonjour je m'appelle nicolas je suis
masseur professionnel et je vais vous
montrer comment avec des manoeuvres
simple faire un massage ou que vous
pourrez reproduire facilement à la
maison je vais bien aborder le sous
vêtement pour éviter les taches d'huile
et je vais pouvoir appliquer mon huile
alors on va éviter d'appliquer l'huile
de verser l'huile directement sur la
peau parce que c'est pas très agréable
je vais venir d'abord la chauffer dans
mes mains et je vais pouvoir l'appliquer
sur l'ensemble du dos je vais partir du
bas du dos avec les mains en parallèle
le long de la colonne vertébrale
jean veloppe les épaules et je
redescends jusqu'aux mains on va
continuer avec une manoeuvre en trois
temps
premier temps sur la zone lombaire
deuxième temps jusqu'au dessous des
omoplates et on revient par les flancs
troisième temps d'une enveloppe les
épaules et à nouveau on redescend
jusqu'aux mains je vais pouvoir
continuer tout en fluidité à passer à
une autre manoeuvre avec des va et vient
sur l'ensemble du dos
la pression est plutôt légère
quel est le risque et on appuie trop
fort là on passe sur l'ensemble du dos
ou passe également au niveau de la
colonne vertébrale on pouvait rester
très superficiel pour cette manoeuvre la
voilà arrivés là je vais m'intéresser à
la moitié gauche du dos puisque je suis
à gauche et partir dans un glisser les
mains alternait le long de la colonne
vertébrale
envelopper les poules est à nouveau
redescendre sur le bras filaments une
deuxième fois on n'hésite pas à faire de
répétition un massage est vide créé la
frustration
si la manawan agréable et là je vais
m'arrêter au niveau de l'omoplate les
mains superposés et faire le pourtour de
l'omoplate
là on va pouvoir mettre un petit peu
plus de pression il ya beaucoup de
tension qui sont logés à haute voix de
l'omoplate
au niveau des trapèzes donc on y va
généreusement arrivé ici je vais
travailler un peu la nuque en pétrissage
avec les mains on pince de cette année
alain qui je vais mettre à la tête de
nos modèles poser mes pouces de part et
d'autre de la colonne vertébrale et
redescendre tout doucement
vous faites bien attention à pas touché
la colonne voilà le monde jusqu'en haut
des fessiers
on revient par les flots